oh ja ich war noch kalter tag
so jetzt angucken sehr gut kommen sie
mit kommen hier reinkommen schaaf schaaf
kommt mit kommen hallo lena die wollen
hier nicht rein
sie müssen hätten sie nicht zu den kühen
weil wir die nachher doch trennen
ich lasse hier ein der dann lasst ihr
eben ein schaf raus dann immerhin ein
schaf weg jetzt mache ich erst ein
bisschen hier ein der das geht so nicht
muss den erstmal ist ganz einfach du
musst den sohn mit hatte machst du das
mal einmal zum reinlassen hatte folgen
die mir nicht was wir machen überhaupt
du musst so an den eingang nein nicht
aus
was willst du denn machen überhaupt erst
einmal schnell und zwar um den baum hier
ich habe keine zeit mehr er macht da
hinten ein weg den die sec teil macht
oder macht es extra hier weg beim ekt
oder doch da können sie raus macht da
hinten beiden act einfach irgendwo weckt
beim weizen okay so
das ist hier einfach so und dann ist es
nämlich ganz einfach aber ich kann dir
wohl neue state building is ok
gleichwertig dann musst du dir einfach
so außen so eine sache so eine sache
hier machen dann können sie darüber
nämlich rein gehen so manchmal drehen
sie sich dann auch nein runter hier die
gäste hier hin so nein nicht lagen
weiter und hierzu nicht schlagen die
unter drin
jetzt wollen die aussage kommt er hier
nämlich auch noch rein sagt fertig wenn
du raus dagegen wie vor wenig plätze
mitreden
ja gar nicht was sie da macht die ganze
mit schafe das hat schon halbtot erst an
leute die rheinstrecke hier rein stecken
hier
tut mir leid was ich was ihr da macht
mit euren schafen
ich weiß dass ich manchmal auch nicht wo
wieder scharf nicht reagieren möchte wir
machen uns jetzt
jetzt kommen sie jetzt kommen sie später
das bfs hatte begann sich immer von mir
an luca vermehren ja genau hat es ihr
lieber zu das zu riskant weil sie sonst
von innen rauslaufen
nein ich hab auch hier die kooks habt
ihr alle jugendlichen manchmal denken
sie sich so der dena ist so schön jetzt
folglich ihm genau kannte man thema
vorgehen damit wir da was hat damit den
zwerg computersüchtige wasser von alex
1999 b was haltet ihr vom computer
süchtigen kommt drauf an wie man das
definiert das wäre nämlich ab werk
erstmal sagen überhaupt computersucht
also wie will man sowas definieren ab so
und so viele stunden vor dem computer
ist man kommt die tatsächlich ja da ist
jeder ist 90 prozent der
büroangestellten computersüchtig also
darum finde ich erstmals man so gar
nicht sagen kann computer sicht jedes
einfach meist also meistens leute die
sowas dann auch wenn es schon in
talkshows oder so im fernsehen ist denn
das leute ich selber irgendwie gar
nichts mit computern zu tun haben oder
sein so die kinder die sitzen nur noch
vom pc die sinkt so stehe ich ja
erwartet das ist ja auch bei let's play
oft gesagt
die zocken kompletten tag ich meine dass
er sowieso eine sache also ich komplett
andere sache das ist ja dann arbeit tag
15 minuten also logischerweise also rund
15 minuten das ist gar nichts man muss
auch sehen dass es arbeiten setzt euch
die köthen oder wollen wir für die neuen
stahl machen
die kommt in den stall im mittleren ja
dann musst du aber dingen zu machen dann
brauchen wir mich ein bisschen bäume und
so warum bäume hier rechnet noch ein
paar jahre wird auch der trotzdem noch
mehr für hühner oder sowas weil wir
wollen ja eine richtige form aufbauen
deswegen nicht so viel platz macht dann
gehe ich ja schon bäume fällen zwar
etwas dazu computer sagt ich sag mal so
alles kommt darauf an ob mal aufhören
kann zum richtigen zeitpunkt
bevor es den wohnhaft hier in aktion der
sucht ist das zwanghafte sondern so
weiter
nur bei mir ist zum beispiel so wie ich
schon mal eine woche weg oder seminar
mich als snack glücklich wer noch länger
weggeblieben aus dass jetzt nicht
irgendwie so viel zu gucken und alles
ich hatte irgendwie auf dem ipod ein
bisschen internetzugriff habe mich aber
nicht eingeloggt übers netz wegen meinen
account habe kein nach hinzu gelesen wer
da nicht gefehlt also ich glaube auch
wenn jemand sagt dass cole der als
computersüchtig dann ist das in 70
prozent der fälle darauf bezogen dass
diese personen noch irgendwelche games
spielt also quasi ja ja wissen sowieso
die schlimmsten dann musste sowieso
wissen mehr oder ananas oder so die
schlimmste meine dass uns das dann auch
oft vorgeworfen die jetzt von wegen also
ich an sich anfangen ich sags mal so
also ich bin zwar letzt player aber ich
zock nix außer minecraft eigentlich also
ich habe damals call of duty gezockt
aber jetzt mittlerweile nicht mehr und
ich zocke ja nichts außer minecraft und
wenn ich vom pc bin dann kümmere ich
mich eigentlich auch nur im youtube um
bearbeitet um aufnehmen und so was und
ich finde dann kann man nicht von der
sucht treten wenn man vom pc sitzt und
ich sag mal kein youtuber ist und dann
den kompletten tag zockt auf wenn
schönes wetter draußen ist dann kann man
schon so ein bisschen von sucht reden
meinen alternativ was kannst du aus
lange weil man wenn nichts zu tun hast
unsere natur wirklich ab so gar nichts
zu tun dass konzerne mit mir ein gutes
wetter ist kam er trotzdem raus gehen
zum beispiel mit freunden ist keiner
zeit wirklich an der zahl gar nicht
langer zeit hat dann ob bei gutem wetter
würde ich mich trotzdem traut kann so
einfach keine zeit ein alibi kann man
natürlich dann sagen ja es hat keiner
zeit deswegen sieht sich vom pc oder
angst aber auch du musst aber auch
einfach wenn du einfach mehr bock auf
nichts auf zocken hast als auf fußball
spielen draußen dann ist das nicht so
dass man sagt ja aber draußen ist doch
viel besser als drinnen das ist das so
pauschalisiert zu sagen wenn man wenn
gutes wetter ist dann draußen kann ich
am pc setzen
finde ich nicht aber man kann sagen wenn
wenn die freunde von einem was machen du
wurdest zum beispiel ja ok
ich wollte dass gerade sagen also wenn
man irgendwie eingeladen wurde irgendwie
fußball zocken grillen märchen und so
weiter und wenn man dann in wien 18 und
dann einfach zu hause allein vor seinem
pc wollte ich dann kann man von sucht
reden aber kann man eigentlich auch
nicht wenn man an dem tag einfach keine
lust hat mal eben wenn man keinen bock
hatte lief einstelligen abend am pc also
ich meine ich meine früher seien bis
tief ins ich finde auch das medium pc
einfach viel besser als fernsehen weil
du im fernsehen wirklich denn einfach
bis derzeit rieselt berieselt wirst und
am pc immer noch selber der bist du
irgendwas macht und nicht nur irgendwie
zurückgeht und genauso wie bei youtube
ich meine youtube ist auch besser als
wenn sie mal die zeiten selber aussuchen
kannst du kannst rund um die uhr sagen
okay das habe ich jetzt verpasst das
gucke ich mir nachher weiter an oder
irgendwie sowas beim fernsehen das ist
halt verpasst du kannst natürlich auch
zeichen etwas viel komplizierter als bei
oder in der mediathek viel umständlicher
aber trotzdem mit youtube da angenehmer
finde ich maradona ist ein anderes thema
sind wir nicht mit mit computersucht zu
tun aber ich finde diese der allgemeinen
definition ist man muss sich da genau
definieren findet dann sollte ein weg
sagen findet ihr dass man also weiter
dass man dann und dann süchtig ist wenn
man dies und die brauche ich finde es
gibt eigentlich diesem begriff der
computersucht gar nicht weil es
überhaupt auch es gibt auch keine
zeitung sucht zeit von gästelisten sucht
ja man kann alles als such betiteln
ja es gibt da etwas ist aber dieser
pauschalisiert der begriff der
computersucht oder der inhaltserstellung
also wieder tragen sind seine zugs
erscheinung wie bei zigaretten zum
beispiel ja wenn du plötzlich wenn du
total schwitzt unsere wenn du dann lange
nicht am pc bis oder sowas
aber was man sagen kann es wenn man
nicht in die schule geht aber dafür vom
pc hängt das finde ich schon heftig ja
aber es ist trotzdem nichts zu tun mit
computer sagt er seine tausende werden
zum beispiel jemand der in der schule
habe ich irgendwie neulich eine
geschichte darüber gelesen oder wie
ja das war auch was mir ich weiß gar
nicht mit mobbing ich weiß gar nicht
genau wie das war aber dass der inhalt
einfach
helles holz boka monat dunkles holz klar
- nein also ich brauch das noch selber
für nach beobachtung des holz ich glaube
das war in den usa und da hat sie dann
auch einfach der ist ein halbes jahr
nicht zur schule gegangen und war dann
zu hause auch vom pc aber das nicht weil
der computer süchtig war sein weil eine
schule einfach total gemobbt wurde und
er einfach im internet seien die
einzigen freunde gefunden hatten so was
will man auch sagen geister total sozial
fremd und sitzt nur am pc und cripple
creek im real life nicht sinn oder wie
man wie man das auch mal so nennt aber
wenn du einfach irgendeinen kaffee und
dann wirklich in der schule einfach nur
gemobbt wird und im internet triffst du
halt einmal viel leichter gleichgesinnte
echte freunde
und nur weil die 500 kilometer entfernt
wohnt kann es jetzt nicht in der
wirklichkeit treffen muss darum auf das
virtuell aus übersee frage ob das
wirkliche freunde sind
na ja das wollte ich auch gerade sagen
im internet findet die wirklichen
freunde ich denke natürlich kann man
mädchen richtige freunde jetzt auch nur
ob sie zum beispiel früher per
brieffreundschaft getroffen hast
irgendwelche das war also freundschaft
erkennst du alles nicht wahr als vor
einer generation bau von henry
freundschaft ja aber das es so ausgiebig
betrieben wurde
das war früher ganz ganz da hat sich
jeder vierte fünfte oder so hat er in
der jugend einen brieffreund einfach mit
dem man mit immer ausgetauscht hat und
niemand den man wirklich kannte und dann
hat man manchmal dann als man 50 war die
dann zum ersten mal getroffen
wasser gehört freunde müssen ja nicht
nur welche sein die man auch körperlich
jetzt hier die man einfach aussieht naja
dagegen habe ich gar nicht alle menschen
verständigen ist inzell wird immer soll
es böse hingestellt aber nur im internet
und so weiter ich finde es einfach ein
medium wie jedes andere
beim echten freund kannst du auch die
fressen wenn etwas verkackt management
weiß ich bin heute was unternehmen wenn
echte freude der weiß auch wie die auf
bestimmte das weiß man jetzt vielleicht
internet freundschaften auch aber
allgemein halte ich nicht so viel für
leute von leuten die ihre haupt kontakt
im internet haben ich weiß nicht keine
ahnung sehen wir nicht so mein fall
ich hatte es nicht so pauschalisiert
wieder allgemein halte ich nicht so viel
von leuten das interesse mich dann erst
mal ausreden alter du redest zwei
minuten am stück ich dann meinung du
redest nach zehn sekunden dazwischen
ich finde die hilfe freunde also ich
habe freunde die ich jetzt seit zehn
jahren kenne früherer grundschule
getroffen weil es so zusammen
aufgewachsen und so weiter und ich finde
im internet freut du weißt nie man kann
sich im internet immer für eine andere
person ausgeben die man gar nicht ist
und das finde ich eigentlich schrecklich
andere sagen natürlich wäre ja im
internet kann man sein wenn man will
auch wenn man in der schule gemobbt wird
kann man im internet hier der ovag in
seiner weil sowas will ich eigentlich
schrecklich man sollte so sein wie man
während das wie man wie man ist und wenn
er jetzt einen freund im internet findet
den hat total toll findet das kann in
wirklichkeit noch so ein schlimmer kerl
sein
der letzte deiner sache von wegen
ja die echten freunde findet man im
internet nein mann ich eben nicht jeden
echten freund finden im internet die
wenigsten aber man kann es trotzdem und
manche finden sie halt nur so weil sie
halt einfach ansonsten vielleicht auch
einfach nicht den mut haben zb leute
anzusprechen oder so was was weiß ich es
gibt ja alles und es sondern einfach
durch durch das medium internet ist aber
so schaffen es gibt sie alle ist später
zwei spart möchte dazu noch stellung
nehmen
als gedanklich ein bisschen nebenbei
abwesend beim hausbauen hoffentlich ja
sehr immerhin schon
ich sehe in halbe sache aber wenn ich
mir das so überlege der im sturm ece
waggon ic waggons noch fehlt ist ein
ernsthafter auf die ganze zeit dass wir
die ganze zeit wenig zu machen ich meine
du hast nicht mehr
du hast eine wand männlich ich hab mich
sagen dass es nicht so lief ich habe
andere nicht sehen kann oder habe ich
habe die komplette familie aufgebauten
weg habe ich hier gemacht was ok ist
doch toll ist auch toll das ist doch
toll du hast du aber ich war die ganze
zeit scharfe suchen und ein bisschen
verreckt wow ich bin ich nicht jedoch ab
ich habe alles wieder bekommen das ist
im boden wow cool ich habe bisschen
angst vor dir warum das handy mit
schwert ankommen
oh ja ich war noch malta park was war da
los war dein körper einfach mal rein
theoretisch betten machen oder können
wir haben genug denn das mal machen
ich denke fest im fest gepackt ich kann
mich bewegen als gc das parkhaus zu dem
auch weil er geholt von den schafen
feuchtem eine schere noch erwarte ich
kann nicht einfach drei wolle geben
ich bin sie bräuchten sheriff was
anderes was er ich würde sagen weißt du
nein ich brauche blätter was sonst den
sozial ich gebe ja sogar sachen ab du
bist zu alt er von denen habe ich ja
schon geklappt da geht nichts ab was
habt ihr kohle gegeben ja ich weiß ich
habe mir ja 15 holz geholt bei dir von
den dunklen holz er ist also da ja jetzt
gedanken wird dafür jetzt kriegst der
matte muss gucken was habe ich denn
überhaupt christ 2 äpfel
zweifellos kann ich gebrauchen
wo sind genauso groß die meisten äpfel
foto kalle weiß hier oder sind als auch
teilweise gebraut raue schafe alle
weisen ob ich mir sicher wir können aber
färben feierlichkeiten mitbauen mir aber
irgendwie sind jedoch alle ich glaube
ich hatte welche aber die sind wir dann
irgendwie auf dem modell mit was sonst
seit wann kann man schafe mit bauen wir
färben mit was denn sonst
du musst bauen wir mit einer rose oder
so zum beispiel in crafting sony mit
farbstoff hermachen mir ja echt mal ich
dachte bei mir ist ein farbstoff musste
erst mit allerhand bis oder so einen
tintenfisch teile
damit können wir einfach einfach
rechtsklick drauf machen dass ihr nur
blau färben wieder was weiß die sind auf
weiß in welche grau sind die fährt man
sie dann weiss starb es geht irgendwo
junge kommt mit einem schwert nicht so
fern